well I mean one of them's got to have a
map on them right so can you help me no
no no no
it's over
we are going home
in my [__] home yes it is it's true
he loves you girl oh grass is greener
inside
because I like that remark I'm sorry
it's like damn girl it had to be like
this I'm staying girl you can't stay for
who
our luck had to run out sooner or later
damn
it you'll be like that [__]
wait Joel how did you not catch on but
the childhood friends show me this child
doesn't want to believe it he loves her
whatever
I know what you are but what you are
your skin Sparkles yeah you're seeing
Sparkles oh
touch me
oh that'll be fine yeah let's rub some
men's apple cider vinegar oops
whoops oh okay
I don't know no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no John I want to
go home no I don't want to go home
we had a training on this one like a
mouthful of spaghetti that was very
spaghetti for moldy spaghetti like
typical Friday night
oh my God
what a way to go that's honestly out of
anyone in this show so far the worst way
to go the worst way to go make it out
well the green but the grandma also made
out with the tentacles but this one this
one is like you know like this is a
horrible example but like if you're like
oh I'm drunk and I just want to go get
my spaghetti out of the fridge try
eating the spaghetti that's been in
there for three months and then you see
the hair on it and then you're there but
you felt it going down your throat
penicillin
doesn't hurt you makes you stronger
welcome back to New Rockstar rocks The
Last of Us episode two is here and God
damn it dog
names you knew was coming just didn't
think it was coming this fast I thought
we had one more episode please great
actress she turned it up for this and
I'm here for it uh look out uh Ellie's
chicken sandwich you're next oh God that
was a good looking chicken sandwich yeah
how the hell they get gourmet Chicken
Sandwich Michelin five star we'll talk
we'll talk this is the break room Our
Daily Show that keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news that you need to know
about and today we're talking about The
Last of Us episode two so kick your feet
up on some spilled oil barrel and plug
into the hive mind as we dive in baby
I'm Jessica Clemens and with me today is
Brandon Barrick hello happy to be alive
and Anna Vincent
oh no she's turning
that's the prettiest fungus I've ever
seen the prettiest
yeah
it's just so bad okay
as a reminder the first part of this
episode will be spoiler free uh we
recommend if you haven't played the
games to avoid reading the comments if
you don't want to be spoiled just stay
away from there if you're in the
comments don't be spoilery come on Pete
let people appreciate this show and the
story they're telling uh there are a few
foreshadowing moments in this episode
for folks that have played the game so
we'll be leaving those out at the end of
the episode in a recap and covering them
at the end so if you do any spoiler talk
it'll be at the very end we will warn
you we will tell you uh you'll be warned
uh but for now the episode begins with
another incredible code open very
different from the game new stuff that
we hadn't seen before an Indonesian
Mycologist is taken from her lunch and
brought to her research facility she
inspects the body of a young woman who
had been infected with the cordyceps
virus while working on a grain and
Flower Factory can we talk about the
green and flower fact real quick well if
you saw it we put out a short on new
rock stars talking about how we had
guessed that obviously in the in the
game it comes from imported crops we've
been over this in this one it's
originating from a green and Flower
Factory which we put the puzzle pieces
together Craig Mason was like yeast
yeast uh Craig Mason was like in a
little interview he's like we've left
bread crumbs and then Eric delved into
in the short into how what are all the
examples the Bold one the old woman's
being fed biscuits they don't have
pancake mix they don't have they run out
of pancake mix he doesn't bring the cake
home no no raisin cookies no raisin
oatmeal raisin cake
it's a great little device and yeah if
you're not listening HBO as an official
uh after Show podcast watch this first
listen to that uh Craig Mason and Neil
druckman uh talk about the show and the
game and how are things related they did
say we left little breadcrumbs in that
first episode so literal like confirmed
right it's not crops but it's spreading
through the food it's in the food folks
and I want to come I'm going to put a
little pin in put it on the internet
yeah yeah yeah so uh we discovered this
is starting at a flower factory 14
people are unaccounted for they're
probably out there biting folks uh when
asked for advice on how to create a cure
Dr radna very coldly told the Indonesian
military to bomb the whole city very
funny very honest and I love that later
we see they tried bombing Boston
Strong I said if they start every
episode with a little bit and then it's
about episode and when they did that I
was like oh hell yeah but also how Ruth
was of a human how rude I love her I
mean can I go be with my family because
this thing is gonna kill everybody
because the guy was like we need a
vaccine we need a cure and she was like
[__] you better be joking God all right
no kid for this oh what extra sucks is
that it shows that like especially in
the first episode in the beginning
scientists were like yeah dude we got
you guys and it's so frustrating to be
like why wouldn't you try to work on it
almost 40 years past and they still
don't have an answer because they're
like I can't get it it sounds like a lot
of things that we have today
wow Tess and Joel monitor Ellie through
the night and she doesn't turn they take
her through the outskirts of the qz and
Ellie tells tells Tess about how she was
bitten and asked questions about
bloaters and clickers which she doesn't
know are voters I think she says is it
true so it's not true they're ones that
click like a bat and it's like scores
the scores and they're like no that's
crazy we've never heard of that and then
she asked about like the blind ones that
live in the dark and click and they're
like they look at each other like we
can't tell her that's real because it'll
freak her out but it's real we've seen
it also when they came out and you hear
the Screech of one and they're like
let's just keep moving I was like maybe
turn around yeah there's also a moment
when uh if you've played the game when
they're leaving that first little setup
and Joel opens the door it makes like a
clicking noise
it to me was like oh that sounds like
the game or whatever and I think it was
to make the people play the game jump a
little bit to think like oh is there one
right there already uh we also learned
that the infected act as a high fine
stepping on a patch of cordyceps in one
area can activate a group of the
infected miles away I love that
my god when it okay so when they got
inside the building and went under the
fingernails I was like first off that is
everyone's fear I'm ripping off
fingernails yeah and then for it to just
start connecting and you see that some
are dry spots yeah oh good so good so
good I it seems I don't know listen I
know why they I understand why they did
it it seems um pick and choosy to me
like it's like well that does that apply
for every infected that's still moving
around like I guess so I think it does I
think it all connects to each of them
it's weird because like when it comes to
Horticulture the plants interact in such
crazy ways go watch The Happening folks
I took it to me if you're like a mobile
if you're like a clicker right and
you're walking around and you're not
attached to the to the uh spread and you
get killed no one knows but if it's on
the ground because we've seen it unlike
the game there's much more like spread
out of the fungus from a corpse right so
I like that idea that like they're just
waiting eating because if if this fungus
is sentient enough that it's like
keeping itself alive it's saving
resources like I'm not gonna put liquid
onto all of my spreadable fungus I'll
just wait till I need it I don't know I
don't know okay okay all right so keep
going through the episode the group has
to cut through a museum since the long
way is being uh guarded by a new horde
of infected and we get to meet our first
clickers and Ellie very quickly very
smartly was like we should not go in
there that place looks bad it's like
that's fine they're probably dead by now
uh Joel bags two kills here uh but not
before both Tess and Ellie get big
Ellie's fine at the Capitol building the
group figures out uh that one of the
fireflies had been infected and killed
the rest as Joel puts down the last of
the infected a horde of Runners nearby
are Hive mine triggered and make their
way to the group they're speeding and
this
is uh they they run like cheetahs I
don't know why I made you stronger Tess
holds them off using spilled oil Barrels
in her charm
and Joel and Ellie make it out alive her
sweet sweet charm that I it was also it
gross gross to think about but I was
wondering if they reacted that way
because they were like oh not only is
she infected but she's not running yeah
she's standing there I know though The
Crazy Ones wore but the one that was
like already turning into a clicker was
like she's not running I took that
moment as like yeah but one's running
past her I feel like they didn't even
see her because they're like oh she's
already infected we don't need to go
after her like they could already tell
immediately like whatever they're
smelling or the fungus itself but I
didn't know if the kiss was like she's
starting to change and it was like her
she was almost compelled to join up with
another part of the fungus or she was
just so scared she was she could see
herself in this guy like this is gonna
be like why did she stay still yeah yeah
yeah I I mean I definitely think that
moment to me was definitely a contrast
between the affection she wanted from
Joel and then like what you know it was
a contrast there it was like she's never
able to get that affection I I thought
it was just that she was like she's
still smart and a woman that was like
I'm gonna go down I'm gonna go down
swinging right so I think she was just
like as many that can get in this
building as possible yeah just wait as
long as she can before I get infection
get them all in here we'll get a line
going do you think Tess intended to hide
her bite for longer okay okay was it
Ellie's deduction that made her come
clean when Ellie figured it out pretty
quick or was she just working herself up
to telling Joel and Ellie because in the
museum after both clickers have been
killed Joel asked Tess if she's all
right she responds twisted ankle but
yeah uh it's possible with all the
adrenaline she didn't realize she had
been bitten but she's a smart lady she
knew right away and she had been bitten
right yeah no she knew I think she was
just waiting until the it got worse also
you never know the situation you're
gonna be in when the situation happens
so I think and I think she is driven by
the fact of like we have an opportunity
to actually change the world to
absolutely like revert it back to what
it was so I think she was just holding
on to like as long as I have as long as
I have but I know the second it happens
I will tell Joel and he'll kill me yeah
I don't I don't think she ever would
have put Joel at risk I think she is
smart enough to know where she was
bitten and so about how long she had I
think that's why uh when they cross over
that little playing thing she's like
let's go before Sundown like she's
really interesting yeah we saw in that
first episode we saw that lovely
handy-dandy chart uh before they gave
that little kid all the toys that they
ever wanted uh that said like if you're
bitting the head and neck it's like five
to fifteen minutes before you turn if
it's like shoulder arm like that it's
like two to eight hours big big gap big
gap it was like it was huge it's kind of
in between somewhere in between so like
and they were kind of still far from the
capital at that point gotta do a little
climbing stuff 45 minutes to an hour
maybe so I think she was absolutely just
like I think Tess is team cure she is
team I need to get this little girl to
the Firefly so they can make a cure for
Humanity yeah and so but I don't think
she would have put Joel at risk if she
like felt it I think she started feeling
it luckily I I'm sure Joel would have
been like oh we got a killer or at least
what would actually happen if she would
have changed as Joel would have been
like choked up a little bit and then
Ellie would go Ellie would have been
like killed this lady we got it uh so do
you think the bite made her do the kiss
if you want to talk about the kids bite
me well the the amazing kiss all her or
is that some fungus acting out I'm
listening and I'm more concerned about
the symbolism of it okay and I I really
do think it is that the contrast of what
she couldn't get from Joel and what she
got in the end what I also love about
that moment is it's during when she's
trying to light the thing and then when
she does do it she finally likes it I
think this is a metaphor for her not be
able not being able to get the spark
between them and when she finally does
get that flame she's dead I I think it's
a great moment I mean that's disgusting
she broke Joel's heart when he was like
let's go home and she's like that's not
my home I think that was hard for Joe
man because I think get over it
that's all he had anymore was that
little patch of awful land inside the qz
right but I love how she says in that
last in those last moments between her
and Joel she says oh what is the exact
quote I never asked you for anything not
to feel how I felt it's like I was like
it's so much deeper than they were they
had a physical connection but probably
they were I would take it to be in this
kind of world where everyone has
post-traumatic stress syndrome they're
afraid to open up right because the
second you fall in love with someone
they're gone you know I mean it's too
risky you can't you can't lose it all
again so I think both of them were
guarded and when they would try to have
their moments they probably never synced
up they never got that spark right uh
yeah and I think I I don't think Ellie
was ever trying to hide her infection I
think she knew she was bit she's down
100 for this cure idea remember she's
the one trying to convince Joel like
she's like this is real like look at
this I could test your sandwich oh sorry
yeah yeah these names
thank you uh Tess knew she had to get I
think Tess knew she I got to get these
guys as close to the fireflies at the
state capital as I can and I will push
it for as long as I can because Joel
listens to me something great that uh
Craig Mason and Neil druckman talked
about in the uh their podcast for the
first episode was that they've made it
very clear that Tess is the boss here
right Joel does whatever Tess says she
even tells them you know save who you
can save you can't save me I'm gone you
got to go and that clicks in his head he
gets that and he listens and he has to
drag Ellie away who's like no we gotta
help her and she's like no she's done
we're getting out of here I mean maybe
take a few of those grenades with you
the gamer and me was like you're dumping
all these grenades on the ground these
boxes are full of grenades grab a box
gotta go also you know not to be that
person and yes the game 100 yeah my
biggest fear with the game is always
like the noise so it's just like if I
set off a grenade yeah yeah
I mean kill as many as you can I like
that uh but Ellie or Tess knew she had
to get LA to the state capital and then
it'll be fine I can die once we get to
this place and I think her getting there
and seeing that like oh no they're dead
too just devastating and she's like
let's blow this is this mother you know
what I mean let's let's take them all
out honestly the most hardcore thing I
love her it was pretty hard
except for as soon as I got
so I assume from this point too like uh
there's kind of that truck we saw was
that the fireflies trunk we implied
that's their truck was it not the okay
so it was that was that an old Federal
truck but they said in the first episode
that fireflies have access to like
access to Federal stuff they've stolen
some federal stuff oh so do you think
that the person that was led the blood
inside from that truck was a firefly
that killed the rest of their team
inside that yeah yeah oh so yes has to
be a firefly truck I hope so I hope
they're going to take that truck a bunch
of crazy people that are still outside
and uh because I saw that gasoline and I
was like if this is OG gas that's been
in the state capitol since the outbreak
it can't be good anymore this is
something that gets brought up sometimes
in zombie things and sometimes forgotten
and zombie things that over time
gasoline will Decay and separate and no
longer be gasoline uh you know so I I
took it to be like maybe that's fresh
stuff that they were just
they've moved it inside I don't know I
don't know how long they were planning
to be there who knows but it seemed like
the gas still lights on fire that's the
good part oh yes that's where you were
getting to I was trying to follow
they're going to take this truck or if
they're going to be on foot from here
still I don't know that's the problem is
that it's the battery I know but if this
is a good working truck who cares about
the battery like please
wouldn't it be a different battery
technically in that big ass truck yeah
you can make it work oh so uh just go on
foot get away from this location that's
on fire that probably set off an alarm
for every clicker just go on foot real
quiet as possible until you're yeah but
they got a long way to go yeah but then
you've also got Ellie being a little
wild right now so just let her cool down
walk it off if she's wild right now oh
wait did she really want uh
she's gonna keep getting bit
I first thought was like Joel should be
more afraid because I'd be like okay you
get bit once in your phone what happens
when you get bit twice as long as you
get bit three times
he brings it up he's like well what
about the second bite we don't know
anything about that right yeah yeah that
was that was a great Mama too when she
was like ah good thing it was me
[Laughter]
uh well we got we're gonna talk about
for this episode uh but first we want to
thank our sponsor for this episode and
that's Factor this new year you've got
goals stay alive don't get killed by the
cordyceps uh and factor is here to help
you achieve them sick of eating
apocalypse chicken sandwiches I know I
am save time and have the energy you
need to tackle everything on your to-do
list with factors ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door get
factor and not only skip the trip to the
grocery store but skip the chopping the
prepping and cleaning up factors fresh
never frozen meals already in just two
minutes you've got two minutes to heat
up a meal so all you have to do is just
heat it up and enjoy it'll be delicious
Factor has meals that are keto keto
right
oh yeah yeah
factors has meal Factor has meals that
are keto calorie smart vegan and veggie
and full of protein prepared by chefs
and approved by dietitians each meal has
all the ingredients you need to feel
satisfied all day long with 34 Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's always something new to
try plus you can round out your meal and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of 36 plus quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons this is everything you need to
eat is right here at Factor because each
meal is prepared by chefs and approved
by dietitians you know that your Factor
meal has all the ingredients you want
and nothing you don't get Factor enjoy
clean eating without the hassle simply
choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor-packed meals delivered to your
door ready in just two minutes there
really is no easier way to eat well
achieve and maintain your goals this
year with Factor get America's number
one ready to eat meal kit and start
saving time eating well and living your
best year ever head defectormeals.com
break room 60 and use code break room 60
to get 60 off your first box that's
codebreak room 60 at factormeals.com
break room 60 to get 60 off your first
box keto is Neato keto is
but get on Atkins so you don't get a
cordyceps yeah uh okay here's another
question I have for you folks did
Marlene know that the fireflies at the
Capitol were dead did she set up Joel
and test in the hopes that they
continued taking Ellie West oh my God
yeah did Marlene when she sent them on
this Quest she's been stabbed she's left
behind him boss in the qz and Boston
she's like I can't okay you gotta take
it the fireflies will get her out there
did you think Marlene knew at that point
that they were already dead and she
hadn't had radio contact with them and
she was like I'll just get them to there
and they'll keep taking it the thing is
I think she believes that Ellie is the
goal so why would she send her to a well
Marlene you know she was very practical
in the first episode you know she's
telling her her like Lieutenant like
we're not doing great we're getting
nowhere uh we're gonna forget this whole
like gorilla Warfare stuff let's focus
on the Cure right but she could possibly
at that point have lost radio contact
with the people at the State House like
I'm not answering they're probably dead
or maybe she heard on the radio like
but she's like I can't ask uh a Jolin
test to just take this girl West I'm
gonna tell him to go to the State House
they're gonna get there there'll be some
supplies there and possibly some days
[Applause]
you are trying to get them all killed
this is unfounded speculation these are
the thoughts of a woman who's been
stabbed and uh
you you're writing the prequel in
between
I'm doing my best I think you are and I
think that would be very funny if she
was like well maybe they'll run into a
hoarders but maybe they won't chances
are very high she's playing it all out
Tess gets bit here and then Joel's
inspired so we have I've planted a
makeout zombie at this point
what's better than three people than two
people you know what's up he did have a
little too tousled hair neatly yeah I
know it I genuinely think zombies
someone's gonna comment it and we should
say it now
comments
at Jessica
come from me you're the living thing I'm
sorry do they come back to life after
dying no I'm joking I interrupted them
uh I forgot what I was gonna say it
wasn't gonna be that helpful to be
honest
um but no it's I think she was actually
actively trying to send them somewhere
but the thing is like I don't care how
close to death you are how like whatever
I think you should have been much more
like yeah I talked to him yesterday
before being like I I and I understand I
understand we're living in a
post-apocalyptic time now but it's like
you can't like hope that they're gonna
get there three people on foot through a
world of zombies I mean and there could
have been more off camera we didn't see
but yeah she didn't she didn't List
names she didn't say like a time all I
remember is her cussing at her friend
and being like you have no earrings
right right that was great the Lord said
it was like I'll take her she's like you
don't need wraps [__] here dude come
on
I guess it don't happen here uh she
still got an ear hole that's true good
point Brandon thank you thank you she
needs a cheerleader at this point
someone's got a room someone's got it
yeah she's just gonna keep getting
custom well I'll ask I'll ask you guys
do you think they're gonna go back to
but to that quarantine Zone at all or do
you think Joe and Ellie from here
they're out they're not good enough
because Joel wanted to go back this
whole time he wanted to go back and now
he doesn't have tests to say we can't go
back they're gonna find the Dead Guy
they're gonna find a dead sergeant that
he beat to death right oh that's not
trying to say this in like a horrible
way but he wasn't mauled by a zombie
right he punched in the face repeatedly
and if two people come back to the qz we
already saw how they treat that child
that's true like if two people oh we saw
how they hung people yeah
so it's like they're also like are you
the two that punched one of our guys's
face who you've been talking to we've
seen you guys it's a closed off center
we see you guys go over by the brick
wall and talk we know sometimes are a
long time and now his face is bludgeoned
in no zombie does that also Joel we saw
you on the side in that plastic bag
I think yeah I think if they flash if
they go back to the quarantine Zone it
will either be to pursue maybe fedra
going after them or maybe showing how
Marlene eventually Ventures out and goes
on her Tuesday yeah she'll have to come
out um because in the game we don't see
what Marlene does after that like we
don't uh we don't cut away from Joel
Nelly to see what she's doing we always
focus on them let's talk about it some
of the changes from the game so if you
haven't played the game you don't want
to know the differences go away go away
but we're gonna talk about some changes
from the game all right let's talk about
some similarities some changes uh I'm
gonna talk about I've decided what I'm
talking about similarities that's how
I'm starting this segment and there were
a ton there were a ton there was a lot
of um following the first episode there
was a lot of dialogue taken straight
from the game
um the Hotel Grand which they visit
which they don't say the name of in the
show but in the game it is called the
hotel Grand there is a difference there
too it comes in much later in the game
but they just bumped it up a little bit
earlier they also visit the museum that
was the exact same as in the game in
Pittsburgh
the game the Museum's in Pittsburgh
which where is it in the show this is in
Boston we're still in Boston we're still
no it's in Boston okay sorry I'm coming
back
um
both of those sequences had great like
video game moments and they had this in
the first episode too of like uh
blocking exits yes and separating people
right the first episode had the car
smashing in blocking an Alleyway and
that's that's so video gaming yeah and
this one had like oh there's a ceiling
class and I'm Gonna Leave You two and go
all right or like oh we made it on the
second level of the museum and now it
closed behind us and we can't go out
that way yeah I loved how in that little
cave-in thing he boosts Tessa yeah
definitely a nod to the game he's always
boosting boosting ladies he's always
boosting the ladies yeah I mean if it's
if it's the apocalypse you gotta get
what you can get you boost the lady you
know you boost the lady or two it's
apocalypse an apocalypse with a virus is
wildly it's a fungus sorry fungus which
you can still technically get I mean
when that's if you survive all this and
you get like the flu and die yeah what
if I got ringworm I'm like it's
different it's a different the different
the difference they're only out there
making Hydro they're not making uh
uh no but yeah they have that the the
not the bunch of video game nons they
also I noticed did like flashlights
which she had it seems like something
that's like yeah they had flashlights
everyone does no it's a game knot just
get over it the game not it's definitely
a game nod
um
the backpacks he wraps Tess his foot up
in duct tape
I was trying to find if that was the
exact bandage noise they used in the
game when you bandage yourself I
couldn't find like a good sample of the
bandage noise I can do it for you find
it for me
wow who's that perfect so those were a
lot of the similarities again a lot of
the dialogue pulled straight from the
game
um but let's talk about some differences
uh the opening in once again wasn't what
it was in the game we don't ever see
Jakarta or this whole uh Professor thing
that's all completely new
um as we touched on last week there's a
there's a tweak in the origin and as we
talked to that in the beginning with the
bread and the crops um okay so we skip a
big chunk of the Boston cuese Escape in
favor of the scene with Joel Tess and
Ellie waking up in the morning which is
new I also really love in this scene
that when she wakes up
um she's in like a pool of light and
surrounded by Moss which is a great
contrast to Justin Joel just I wasn't I
was in there for a moment I remember
that scene
who are standing in the darkness on
concrete I also thought this was I think
they might have been trying to do the
same thing in episode one where we see
Ellie when she's being held captive she
lives up at the wall and she says when
you're in the darkness yeah the rest of
it being look for the light and she's in
a little bit
um so I think this might have been sort
of the same thing the contrast of the
two characters and how we're being like
hope and the light yeah I did see during
that conversation she's in the light and
he's in the dark yeah yeah I love that
he's like ready to kill her let's go
let's kill this girl
um so there it I agree with their
decision to
um swap swap these things out because
it's just it's more about the
relationship than the sneaking out well
there's different audiences here a video
game you have to give the audience
something to do more action more
elements of like doing stuff the show
we're all experiencing it the same way
in that we're being shown the same stuff
so I think it's smart to like move
things around to make them narratively
more interesting for sure there are also
some completely practical differences
like technically because uh whenever she
after that scene whenever they got into
the line she's like the world for the
first time are those slanty buildings
that moment actually takes place at
night in the game as uh uh in addition
to the um Museum like all that stuff
takes place at night when they have that
conversation of like we can take the
long way or the you're [__] dead way
yeah you don't you don't get a choice
you don't get a choice just go the way
that you go it's very uh one-tracked um
and also the hive mind aspect effect of
the fungi infected all being connected
that is new to this and obviously they
set it up in the beginning and it paid
checkoffs fungi is what I call it pays
off in the end there uh in the museum
Joel's the one that has to go alone
instead of Tess who sticks with Ellie
Ellie getting bit again is also a new
detail from the game uh normally Ellie
can walk through rooms with spores uh
but there isn't a plot point of her
getting bit a second time
um but Tess does in the game she she
also gets bit she also hides it uh yeah
so that that part is pretty much we'll
talk a little bit more about that when
we get to full spoiler territory here at
the end we'll talk more about the tests
and then finally when they arrive at the
Capitol building it's um normally in the
game it's the fedra soldiers soldiers
that they have to that are after them
and they show up at the building he had
they have the whole like I'm bit
still bit she shows the uh in the game
he when he finds out she's bit he does
back away a little bit but there's not
the moment of her walking towards him
and him backing away which I feel like
is a lot more powerful and that moment
in the game is also where the game hints
that there may be in a relationship but
it's never as expressly said in the game
like we said uh the first episode it's
never expressly said in the game they're
like they're in a
relationships
with thinking back I was talking about
last episode of us doing this
um I was like oh they for sure called it
out when she put her arm around him but
now I'm like no because there's a reason
he didn't like cuddle against him
oh my God
put the bag away
I was like no you didn't should have
been killed my Lord so yes uh normally
the federal soldiers are coming and Tess
says I will hold them off and you will
have to run uh she blow them up I forget
she shoots him and she didn't really get
that far when it's a full Army yeah I
like that switch from the game that it
was um then give that reveal a little
bit later in the show give this moment
for Tess yeah uh make it just a
character that we already have seen the
zombies and tests well I'm already
scared of fedra this heightens our fear
of like what the zombies are capable of
and shows that like oh because they
weren't already there they got called
there very very very threatening uh one
more thing one more thing
they didn't do any music it was just
like no scream these music videos
no there's no call keep going
um in the museum when uh Ellie and Joel
are like asking each other questions
after test goes up and notice that uh on
each side of the hallway they're on
Joel's wallpaper is almost completely
peeled off of his side and Ellie's is a
little bit peeled but not completely I
thought that was some symbolism for like
how much [__] they had each gone through
and how like Ellie is still relatively
fresh and new and jealous oh this is the
moment in the hotel you said the museum
but I think this is the hotel yeah when
it's right after yeah I loved that
sequence what a great scene for the both
of them yeah uh you know him goading her
her goading him like uh
it reminded me they were both trying to
be vulnerable but yeah when I talked to
my nieces and they say something smart
to me and I lose all of my composure as
an adult and I'm like well you're stupid
it's like it was just great and it was
so believable and just like just he's
beginning to open up a little bit for
this girl but he doesn't want to love
again he's not even lost his daughter
every time I watch it I'm like this is
Joel no offense to the child act I was
playing Ellie I'm like this is Joel this
is the little girl from Game of Thrones
and she is so hardcore she said she's
not letting that man in she's hard for
it the knife flips badass badass
um
uh let's talk about kill counts uh this
episode Joel he kills three both the
infected in the museum and the infection
at the Capitol oh they step on a dead
body on the stairs
I was like crunchy beauty Beauty I would
love that it's like stepping on a fall
leaf yeah I would do that that's the
only part that I would enjoy in this in
the show the lovely sounds of the human
husks in the fall uh Tess Tess has a
tough kill count to count uh because so
many were piling in from off screen she
blows them up we could see about 38
before we last couple you probably
wanted it we could see about 30.
yeah I really slowed down that kiss
um Ellie zero kills uh this episode
she'll get it she'll she'll get it soon
enough uh and the infected we'll give
them one they got Tess
I mean we saw we also saw that freshly
killed dude
yeah that was interesting I love that
scene because it I was like oh there's
other people
this is fresh as hell yeah he's fresh as
hell yeah you saw like two skeletons you
saw the husk of a human this is a fresh
body yeah it's like fresh area when
they're at that hotel and overlooking
the street and there's the people just
kind of laying there and as the sun
comes comes by them they don't like the
sun because it dries them out more the
big horde where they were the rippled
they did the waves yeah yeah yeah
they come across the stadium and the
fungus has set up a football game fungus
versus fungus and the stands are full of
people and there's like the popcorn guy
like oh my God he's just got hands like
human hands and people give me the
mascot is
[Laughter]
dude I want to see a fungus football
game let's go let's do it it's a free
one Mason that would be spreading so
fast
but they don't have like control of
their bodies which I love like in that
first episode they showed that like the
cordyceps just activates the Instinct
that's why the dude when he's chasing
him through the restaurant yeah he's
just crashing into stuff like doesn't
have control of his body like I love
that idea Focus trying to play football
but they're just I want a big foam
finger with like a bite mark
dude
hit us up hit us up um okay let's get
into a little more spoiler set this will
be full official spoiler Time spoilers
you talk about anything we want here so
you've been warned so many times at this
point you're still here you're here
uh both the little spoiler three things
that stood out were kind of like Tess
Ellie and Joel stepping over the stuffed
giraffe on the bridge uh which is an
obvious Connection in the moment in the
game that involves a real giraffe but
the stuffed animal is also the same
design as the ones you can find in the
mall during the Left Behind DLC which
we're probably going to see that DLC
play out in the season we already saw a
snippet of it in the trailer Ellie has
talked about the mall we've heard the
name Riley mentioned I would believe it
was lying about being alone in the mall
I could see it being episode three
okay so oh that Ellie lying about yeah
about Riley being in the mall with her I
oh are you about to get into it well
yeah because again you can enjoyed then
I'll come yeah yeah so in that same
sequence where she's talking about the
mall Tess asked Ali if she has a
boyfriend obviously unaware of Ellie's
previous relationship with Riley and her
future relationship with Dina if we're
gonna get there eventually which it
sounds like we are in season two Ellie
also asks if clickers are real and Joel
and Tess avoid the question but they
clearly know it is but Ali also alludes
to bloaters throwing spores and tests
and Joe laugh it off there's a lot of
things I'm like okay what are they going
to touch on in the second season I know
the second season will probably look
more like the second game but I'm like
that are they extending how long it's
going to take to actually see some of
these is infected I don't know I mean
the trailer has shown a bloater we saw
it kind of like in the trailer crawling
and it's it's a big boy it's big he's a
big chunky boy maybe maybe they'll use
the same uh trailer or they they seem to
have indicated that season one will be
the first game season two is gonna be
the second game which I was kind of
disappointed in because I would just see
more in between the two games because
there's so much that's like two episodes
in itself of her getting kidnapped and
then Joel beans well when they were
doing spoiler talk uh if you watch I
love HBO does so much great behind the
scenes stuff the after the show
interviews they do uh they have the
podcast but after the show they do the
trailer for The Next Episode and then
they show like interviews with cast
members they're interviewing someone I
believe it was Marlene they're talking
to Marlene and she's on the set of the
restaurant in the woods and I was like
oh I cannot wait for that scene so good
so so good quickly going back to the
Riley situation I was gonna mention
um it was interesting that she didn't
tell Tess I understand they were not
that close and maybe she you would have
brought it up eventually but I think she
feels bad about it and clearly what was
it like in the game they were like or no
I think they no did they mention the
game or did they already mention the
show where she's genuinely like well
we're just gonna sit it out here and
just wait until we turn uh Riley was
like let's just stay here and wait yeah
that's in the game because we haven't
seen Riley at all on the show they
mentioned her name in the first one like
Marlene kind of brings it up what about
Riley and she's like okay so it was the
same in the game where Tess asks uh how
she got bit and she says I was in the
mall by myself in the show they make it
a little bit more obvious that she well
I don't know maybe if you've played it's
obviously I don't know it looks like
she's like they're saving it for the
writing wise great for storytelling
purposes we've been waiting for the
situation where it's like what happened
to your daughter what happened to your
back because they'll both they're gonna
have something they'll both have this
thing to share with each other the thing
is it's like something to share that
everyone probably has in common because
it's an outbreak everyone has been
affected by it but it's a situation of
like the I think they both feel very
guilty for the situation and it was out
of their own hands it was out of their
own channel when Joel finally gives
Ellie a hug when he lies to her is what
I'm gonna it's gonna be tough so the
mall sequence right we we know we're
going to get it we've seen the trailer
for her in the show in the game the way
it works it's like DLC it's extra
content and it's kind of told as a
narrative flashback where in present
time Joe and Ellie are going through a
mall a different Mall Joel gets hurt he
gets stabbed with some rebar Ellie's
trying to get supplies and we kind of
cut back and forth to this story do you
think that's how they're going to
approach that in the show where they're
in a similar situation and at least
having flashbacks or where Ellie just
kind of shared this story no I hope to
Joel you want to see it play out the
same way I it was well it's so hard
because he was getting chased by a bunch
of people right and he was fighting off
one big guy falls off lands in it and La
has to like literally like lift him up
and I feel like that would trigger the
same moment of you trying to get your
friend out right so at that point game
that to be the recognition right at that
point in the game she's starting to
befriend Joel Moore I mean I've I always
felt like in the game she wants to be
friends with Joel so badly no this one's
a much a much stronger she's being
standoffish too well this guy wants to
kill her I don't know I'm I'm torn
because like I said before I think that
we're gonna get those Riley flashbacks
earlier rather than later but in in the
DLC it doesn't come that plot point
doesn't come until a lot later and I I
also kind of think they're gonna save
that um that huge need of hers to like
save Joel in a certain moment I think
they're gonna save it they might not
well actually if season two has one big
moment then season one also might have
one big moment of Ellie being like I
need to save Joel it's that that part of
the DLC is so big that I want that to be
the justification for anything massive
it's so easy to use it because it's
right after they leave uh Tommy's place
and it's just like we're gonna do this
fine yeah
I don't know I don't it doesn't have to
happen none of this even
because I'm a justification girl
writing wise
but I it's just like that setup you guys
can play anything off of yeah they could
do it any way they want I feel like they
do it in the game because it is DLC they
kind of have to like bring a player back
into it maybe they haven't played the
game in a while and it's also like the
players like I want a more Joel action
you know so it's like I feel like they
do that in the DLC just to make the DLC
Standalone make sense but I think they
could weave it into the show without
them too it's such a good scene
unless he gets like I don't know I hope
they don't they would never get bit but
if he got shot by someone that's an easy
like getaway but I mean the interesting
thing you know uh Craig Mason's already
said injuries are going to be way more
important in this show because they're
not going to heal as fast like you do in
the game well they've already had with
this plus you know him beating the fedra
agent to death at the beginning this
episode you know Tess is like is it
broken yeah you know because that's a
huge deal yeah he's like oh I think it's
just a hairline fracture it'll heal fine
I I think that's gonna come back to
haunt him uh I was already I'm
attracting injuries in this show
in the very first episode when he gets
when his daughter dies he's he when he
gets winged on the side I would love to
see that scar at some point you know
what I mean when he's talking about his
daughter or something these injuries are
gonna pile up and it's going to slow him
down even more unless he can get some of
that sweet Hydro
put the bag down oh look no he's gonna
be like let's go to Atlanta okay there's
a lot
of zombie apocalypse girl we might have
to live during this [__] I'm gonna
be high ass don't bring him to the
pharmacy someone else we got chickens we
got weed baby let's go come on the farms
I don't think I'm dressed in a farm
today
Green Acres over here let's go and
you'll see this happen again later don't
worry about it let's not talk about it
um I will say so obviously in episode
one they used the flashback to show Joe
to show Joel's trauma I wonder if
they're gonna do the same advice to show
Ellie's trauma yeah they have to which
is interesting it's kind of too late for
not too late when I say too late I mean
like you I I would have expected in the
second episode so I'm like third episode
you gotta show Ellie's well I think it's
going to be soon I really do I think
it's gonna be they're really faming
towards it a lot like yeah I don't want
to go every episode with like one little
hint yeah
there's a lot of drama already oh and
for this story that's it for the break
room
we'll be back next week to discuss
episode three but we also do this show
every day live at 3 P.M talking about
all the nerdy news you need to know and
all the dirty news you love follow me at
Lulu Clemens follow Brandon at
grinnenburg Barrick Brennan Barrick and
follow Ann edit it's Anna vanston
subscribe to the break room wherever you
get your podcast and we'll see you
Tuesday thanks for watching bye
everybody
[Music]
foreign